Rossi let's start with you would you
ever share Wellies to your friends let
me have my mouth dear God no okay so
true I will preface one thing I think
it's gross however we were camping once
and Linda didn't have her toothbrush or
it's something happened like it fell in
something dirty and I'm like oh well
just use mine you make it out of trees
yes Linda was like that's disgusting I'm
like no you're gonna have disgusting
breath and I have to kiss you so I'm
like use my toothbrush or I have to kiss
that for the next four days if you've
had children I was helping a camping
emergency I know Jonathan I would share
a home enema kit before I share it too
nowhere